since the first humans harnessed fire
our big brains have been presenting us
with challenges innovations that can
bring us great good and also great harm
in the 15th century the printing press
allowed people to share knowledge
sparking the age of reason and also
appending the established order and
authority of the church learning to
master the winds and navigate the Seas
humans conquered the globe and spread
deadly microbes to populations with no
resistance in the 20th century we split
the atom unleashing a power hitter to
unimaginable 'ti of our own annihilation
the speed with which our machines can
learn has raised the prospect of the
so-called singularity the moment
artificial intelligence bolts beyond us
creating world in which we are no longer
masters and now twin girls have been
born in China who are genetically
engineered with the powerful gene
editing tool called CRISPR caste 9 their
altered genes will be passed to their
children and to their children's
children we have discovered a tool that
bypasses natural selection giving us
direct control over the levers of
evolution and again we are challenged
this tool can bring us great good more
food less disease or great harm can we
learn to use it wisely
[Music]